also gallon rush my name bad welcome
back to killing in freaking out starts
last episode was not fun it was not
funny there's not funny but anyway under
this poo back in to having big hey I
would assume we have to go there I love
how we don't even need the key we just
pick it up and the freakin door blows up
alright I'm gonna try not to cry this
time I ran a stairs nothing bad has ever
come from stairs
except maybe people falling up from them
and dying I guess I'll be careful
I'm not gonna die here I don't think you
can die in the stairs anyway alright
what's that I focus pity I need fine mr.
cher Bono and begin I think we'll be out
of here oh oh oh come on that did not go
as planned
daddy night ah god damn it
[Applause]
alright I survived probably one minute
let's see if we can break a 1-minute
record this time we're gonna go I don't
know yes I went here god damn that's
[ __ ] I thought I closed the door
I like boom and you're like nope we're
back here
really this key will oh I get e I get it
we're gonna go back I'm gonna go back
wrong go back and this door over here I
think was locked before yes hello hello
I'm gonna go get the [ __ ] out of you all
right
I'm bragging like a mouse that's not a
cookie laughs okay awkward along the
loading screen thank you very much bad
everywhere are you hiding aren't ya
you think you can just infiltrate my
home no well barrels all [ __ ] me boom I
come on inside even funny any mine
freaking barrels bones from the sky
freakin yea-ah
I despise alright potato tosser try to
hide stalks it from me
[ __ ] barrels alright what if we get
any nice photos oh you're looking fine
there buddy yep did a hair a rolling
barrel hey how about that that's awesome
oh look it's my dinner my dinner that
night
Oh Matt Dean I'll order good more than
we would imagine having been on today
before I fell so 17 are you in dacor
repair wrong right there Sariah probably
am at last hey potatoes okay mr. Schine
had a pity i waited for you
you wanna relax on me i like you [ __ ] on
me all right Thank You mr. Chang
all right what are we doing here mr.
Syria I don't know PA they're running on
it you'd never know anything of course
I'm a shower what do you think oh Jesus
okay I guess we're looking for a key or
something oh I know
[Music]
all right finally I know what to do
hold the puck crowbar buddy come on show
your strength show that you're a man yes
I know it's break whatever all right
what do we do here all this open for
whatever reason do we got something in
here all right let's continue our
journey to the secret chord to my shop
stranger stranger what are you talking
about bodies we talk we're home boys you
know me right Stefano it's good to see
you I'm sorry that you know we cannot
meet I have 220 thoughts that I would
like to invest in your shop bodies I
will take this lot not a good deal I
know it is a very good deal
let it go team do you not know that you
could find that much money around here
yes I am pretty rich what's a good deal
what does good point is much more than
what that I did not know that you were a
good agent you all right shut up what is
my man I will see you bad yes okay no
surprise no not really
I have you naked telephonic naked all
the things you have to see down here
it's the honor for I it's always an egg
to be asked falling well I first like
know why your Newton horrible disease I
know I'm trying to find a
while being named white dog and I will
continue being naked
now it's okay just walking around naked
makes me feel more uncomfortable
oh no not chaos that's super bad
I hate cash maybe go to Johannes he will
explain Oh No kill the owner with a
dagger or leave him alone it's up to you
well well well well well well well well
what chewy
wait I'm gonna actually save an exit
here
all right let's go back in the games no
that's wrong I would I'd pay
[Music]
not it well well well well mr. share
okay all right of course we're gonna
stab in it's a telephone naked guy
chased my gosh she's [ __ ] teleported
me
that's what you get haha again that's
kind of weird
hahaha your captain pieces yes sir
really make it rain make it rain
okay that was awkward
so hockey Anton says $50 turns out all
right let's get that away
alright so apparently they're supposed
to just click here with the key but the
funny thing is if you open it there's
nothing there what this guy down here
there's no I can't even open it anymore
I don't know kind of bar weird but yeah
you just click the key there
didn't quite figure that out didn't I'll
never know I just wanted just one
popsicle and some Cheerios I barrels I'm
sick of this [ __ ] I just want to end
this why do we always keep fighting and
the box is why are you just die I'm
starting to question everything about
life about stairs how do they work
what why are they so cuddly just gonna
hug them and I focus oh look at this
pipes why do they look like glory holes
with penises coming out of them
oh snap uh-oh better weather you doing
down there
alright we need to know Oh
[ __ ] I'm high oh that was close okay
oh no no I left no it's come down here
okay
we'll just go down here yes all right
oh no no okay we're good all right let's
go down here Oh dad got it
what are you doing bad I'm trying to
make noises down there I see Paul said I
see toddlers
okay give me that chance s tenth alders
that's amazing
alright they've jumped down here I see
more taxes you think we can make this
jump
huh oh whoa well give me that Todd set
oh no it's the water monster down there
[Music]
okay okay we're good we are breaking a
bracket accruing in I just do a tiny
jump here all right on it and then tiny
jump here yes all right that's what I'm
talking about get ready to go there I
suppose but the boy this [ __ ] water
monster and I hate him so much
yeah
that's a more skank sound that's more
scaring sound indeed I don't like that I
don't like that at all
this looks much better in my opinion
Tennent I have something sliding oh no
no just oh you're on a mum oh that's not
go go go go go go run
yes Indiana don't slide Richard Ellis
pity I waited a long time for you this
time what have you been up to
you left me with Boris but this is a
frickin race hey 25,000 don't worry
about money right now free do you know
how much I'm worth you know how much I'm
worth
I'm in freakin gold yes take a guess I
don't know $20 no are you kidding me
double that and maybe we will start
thinking talking
[ __ ] yes I used to panna cotta oh of
course not I never scream for help I'm
Savannah okay it's just hello Dave I do
not be there I get the feeling something
bad is gonna happen tell upon an achy
guy
be careful it might attack you and your
right hump your face that's what they do
little [ __ ] Hey corridor full moon
nights let's actually say hell out of
this hey how you doing I'm just gonna
walk all over you
nice period Wow pretty impressive okay
this is locked which means we have to go
in the corridor of dark nights and stuff
alright Billy don't worry I'm with you
the way all this stuff I don't Josh
Danny I know you don't trust a baby but
you gotta do it you gotta save the
people or Johannes or whatever I don't
even care stop how you doing hi nice to
see you looking fine if you're out of
you stop diner just yeah ah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I love that all right hey just
let's just keep going I can't stop
spinning okay
all right boxes all right go go jump in
it I'm sayin I snuck in behind ya god I
can't open it
ha ha I was a poof a I knew it I [ __ ]
knew it
why is it started ha ha what do you want
from me why would they do that
I don't know stefana Jesus Christ baby
all right I'm gonna end this episode I
hope you boys enjoyed like and favorite
if you did subscribe to come abroad
today
and I'll see you next episode
[Music]